i'm actually planning to do like a watch
party of all four of the movies just
because like why not because like again
i've only seen 3.0 and 4.0 once and i'm
like well like on the stream yeah on
star wars you press play yeah yeah yeah
cause like twitch has a thing i might do
that okay
yeah there's a thing for that now like a
like a watch party function what does it
look like so so basically it's like the
twitch thing it i think it's this is a
relatively new thing but basically when
you do a watch party together now when
you go to that person's twitch page the
person the person streaming is actually
in the corner now and you get prompted
to log into your prime video on netflix
oh [ __ ] and it likes
and it syncs up yeah dude it's like a
brand new thing now yeah my twitter i'm
not streaming yeah i might not have no
[ __ ]
changes holy [ __ ] i can work and watch
yeah so so my twitch partner was like oh
since all the ava movies are on prime
video and twitch has this new thing now
you can easily do a watch party i'm like
oh [ __ ] yeah dude let's do this owns
that too yeah he owns all of these yeah
yeah yeah yeah
of course on amazon
now you know now you can cry on stream
yeah yeah or get very confused okay so i
i gotta ask you
what was your reaction when when all
right well what okay okay okay obviously
no spoilers in this no no i just want to
know what you're i just want to know
what your reaction was
when the credits started when the
credits started wrong i'm sorry i just i
just i just need to gush i just need to
go i've literally
never i think that might be the first
time in my life where the term
dumbfounded
is like actually eligible because like i
think if you had if i had seen myself in
the cinemas right i probably would have
made a face like
f for the entire credits just because i
because my brain i don't think could
process what the [ __ ] i just watched
and like and because i went to go see
with uh ken camiarto who was on the show
right um and uh he was obviously you
know during the credit sequence he was
just like oh i know that animated
like what ken was saying was just going
in one ear and out the other because i
was like ken don't give me more
information i'm still trying to process
everything i literally just watched yeah
and uh yeah i don't know like it was i
think the best way to describe 4.0 for
me was it was very bittersweet yeah
because it's like you've it's it's not
until really those credits end and you
walk out of the cinemas yeah you realize
oh this is really it yeah like i'm there
isn't going to be another movie anymore
yeah i mean maybe there will be maybe
there'll be a spin-off story
this movie franchise has ended like
something i [ __ ] grew up with my
whole life yeah and like
i don't know i was like is this how i'm
gonna feel when like one piece ends or
like that's how i felt when arthur got
cancelled i don't i don't even i can't
believe they cancelled off yeah oh they
got cancelled oh they've got consoles oh
they got cancelled
when like like right after the episode
where i said arthur will never be
cancelled are you serious
it literally got cancelled
oh my god no i just assumed arthur was
going to be there when i had like
children yeah [ __ ] man yeah so like i
don't know like i feel this is how
because i've obviously never experienced
like a show i grew up with like a big
big franchise like that to just end in
my lifetime right like i feel this is
how it's going to be when like one piece
or like jojo or like i don't even want
to imagine what one piece and jojo is
yeah right like i feel that emotion that
i felt at the end of 4.0 is how i'm
going to feel and it's a it's not a
great feeling it was like because
because it's her own life now that i
watch something and i feel something
i've never felt before which is which is
exactly what i felt because this is
something i grew up with something i
always thought would be there right yeah
and then it's just it's just like it's
just over and really does feel like like
a family pet has just died yeah you know
it's like it's something that it really
is it's like
i'm like it's honestly it's that same
emotion i i started [ __ ] bawling
about it because like here's the thing
here's the thing right his thing i
wasn't even hyped for 4.0 yeah right
because like [ __ ] nine years had
passed since the fast since the last
film and i'm just like i'm i'm just like
whatever it's out i'll watch it out of
obligation i love ava but i don't i
could go my entire life without watching
another evangelion movie and i would
have been completely satisfied so i
watched it literally out of obligation
yeah and then like i think the last half
hour hit and i'm just like
oh my god what is this i'm feeling right
now is this is this a feeling of closure
am i am i closing a page in my life
right now i'm just like what is what is
this feeling and then the end credits
fell like the end credits started
rolling and i just process is the right
word because there are so many emotions
coming up at once that i just i didn't
know how to process them all yeah and
you just felt empty and you just just
felt like i i felt like a boy for a
[ __ ] void in my life and i'm just
like
there is nothing that's going to fill
this hole up
that's why i need to talk about it
that's why i'm so desperate to because
because i remember as well like when the
when the first posters for 4.0 got
released in japan the tagline for it was
sayonara evangelion which means goodbye
evangelion and i was like okay that's
kind of a cool
very you know like very like artistic
like
kind of tagline i didn't think anything
over right yeah but then when they said
that line in the movie at that at a
particular scene i was like
no
don't do this to me man don't leave me
i'm sorry i should have treated you
better i should have treated you man i
should have treated you more more right
don't leave me not now
and like that was the moment where i was
like oh okay like this that point i
think really solidified to me how
important this series was to me i'd
forgotten it was until until that moment
and like i've been doing ever since i've
ever since that movie i could i've not
been able to watch anything else i've
not been able to like play any games
because i just feel like the emptiness
you literally can't you literally can't
consume any other media for at least a
week because like i tried to and i'm
just like this they're saying they say
never this is the same they say neighbor
well what's the point i'm really scared
to re-watch it yeah i tried to try
playing a game of league lost i'm just
like don't care
i'm whatever like i'm just like not
nothing's gonna fill this like that
moment after you come you just don't
feel anything
you just sit there like what i'm saying
right now emotionally i i think i've
just reached zen yeah like i i feel like
i'm reach i've reached enlightenment
like like [ __ ] being a monk man like
this is this what it feels like you just
you just like you're just like an open
book and you're just like i've i finally
who would have thought i could become a
monk with a 6.99 i remember [ __ ] and
finally and peace with my life and now
and i just i just wanted to get that out
there so i just want to move on with my
life so so for anyone watching this
who's never seen ava we're not we're not
coming onto here saying that we
recommend you to watch ava it's it's
hard to recommend something it's hard to
recommend now because you're not going
to have the same experience that we had
where you just like where you grew up
with this so and you know like i said
it's it if you're someone who's going in
a tough time in your life then i
honestly recommend you experience it
because maybe i will teach you something
about yourself i was going to say i was
like do you know if you
haven't had any struggles with mental
health is it hard to appreciate stuff
like that i think so i think so because
like i because like after watching like
i've just been binge watching so many
like ava analysis like videos which is
which is like which is like i guess like
my way of coping i think i think ken and
i had about a six hour conversation and
it is a kayak about just the movie we
just watched the entire time yeah and i
think the video that that i like related
to the most in terms of what i felt when
i watched the first time was uh
it was ava bridge
scout scamboli like scam early reviews
did a video called you don't understand
ava
in like sarcastic text you know where uh
where he basically broke down why ava is
like basically a really badly told plot
and really like
like he he basically broke it down in a
way where i completely agreed with him
oh i would have completely agreed with
him because that was basically that was
basically what i was trying to say when
i had watched the first time yeah yeah
yeah i just didn't
resonate or relate to anything that was
trying to do me neither i i i you know i
didn't really feel sorry for shinji at
all i felt like i was supposed to yeah i
was like that's the thing the emotions
were there i mean the execution was not
there i mean like i don't think like you
were even supposed to feel sorry for him
right because yeah exactly i'd like
either you do feel sorry for him or you
don't like a lot of people would do
because a lot of people relate to that
kind of mental space right they can
resonate with that but like the series
doesn't explicitly tell you you should
feel sorry for this person this person
is this it's just that's that's that's
kind of like that's kind of like the
thing that maybe like
no not everyone will enjoy ava not
everyone should enjoy it i mean i i i
wouldn't recommend it to someone in a
very healthy mental state because one
you probably wouldn't get it into i
wouldn't wish for you to be in a bad
mental state to begin with yeah you get
it right yeah but i i mean you know
bojack i thought was great because i i
wasn't depressed watching it but i
certainly was after oh yeah but i mean
like things like bojack and like you
know we we related ava to bojack but i
think like something like oyster punk is
probably closer in terms of like
actually you know presenting a very sad
story in a way that can get anyone of
any mental state
invested in the story of bojack right
like you know bojack in that case was
told in a very like straightforward like
here's the thing that's [ __ ] up you
know this is why you should feel sorry
and for most people they felt sorry yeah
easily presented but like i feel ava in
that sense is almost
so vague with what you what they want
the viewer to feel yeah to the point
where it's like here are the emotions
that you should be feeling but we're not
going to tell you to feel those emotions
specifically that's up to you to decide
yeah kind of thing like i i don't trust
anyone who says they understand eva like
no like you you can you can spend
all like well it just sounds like you
can have an interpretation of it you can
have an interpretation
but to claim to understand i feel like
it's just i don't i don't i honestly
don't think it's possible i'm sure there
are some ava fans that are out there
that are just like i can't believe you
said that i'm actually
but like i've like spent so many [ __ ]
hours watching different people analyze
it different people's interpretation but
like there are so many different
interpretations of the series to begin
with but
i i just think that's that's that's the
thing right there's a reason why we are
still discussing it to this day 26 years
later yeah and i think it will always be
disgusting i remember i remember it was
a couple of years ago i think like uh
when when we were still in the rush of
all these people you know just analyzing
every single piece of imagery from the
tv series right and one that got
discussed a lot was when the angels
explode they created an explosion that
looks like a cross yeah and there was i
watched so many analysis videos being
like this is why arno chose the cross
and why it's super symbolic and blah
blah blah and then a couple years later
they came out with an interview with ano
and they were asking so uh is there any
reason why when the angels explodes it
turns into a cross and he literally just
said i just think it looks cool
it doesn't mean anything i mean all the
anime youtube's like
we spent all this time analyzing
something
that he just put in because it looks
cool
and like and and i feel like that alone
to me
really showed the fact that arno doesn't
think this [ __ ] is deep he just put it
in because it's cool so if you're saying
that you didn't have time or money to
make a proper ending yeah what's the
odds that he had the time to be like no
no change the explosion to across yeah
yeah yeah like this this is why you
should do this because it's symbolic to
the story no because
it's just a love letter it's all the
[ __ ] that arnold likes he's like i think
the cross looks cool let's add that [ __ ]
in yeah i mean at the same time i would
say that maybe he didn't make a
conscious choice he put stuff in just
because it felt right yeah it looked
right and it created a certain tone a
certain mood whatever especially in four
people you can analyze that but to say
that everything had a purpose and
everything was put there for a reason i
think i think no no not everything in
ava i i don't think anna knew everything
that he knew what he wanted to say
especially in 4.0 as well there was so
much [ __ ] in there i'm like that doesn't
make any sense
that doesn't that why is that there oh
[ __ ] it you know what it's on just let
him do what he wants to do